foreign
Colorado and talk to the great guy and
what's up Diane
hey John deloney how are you I'm so good
how about you
good what's up
I have got a
going on in my personal life and I have
a son-in-law and daughter who listens
frequently and he said you know who you
need to ask is Dr John deloney so so
here we are gonna here we are and I've
got a very moral or ethical person so
just so you know well I
that is not true so I'm gonna I'm gonna
so I'm gonna kind of kind of lay it all
out there it's a kind of a long story
I'm going to make it as brief as I can
because
uh go for it it's uh it's been a it's
been a long few years
five years ago first of all I'm 49 years
old I am married for 30 years to just
the most amazing man
we have eight
incredible kids
and um five years ago we took the kids
up to the mountains about three hours
away from home went mountain biking and
he was in he crashed his bike very very
severely suffered
um a traumatic brain injury
that almost killed him
um we spent two months in local
hospitals five brain surgeries had half
of his skull removed
coma you know the all the everything
just horrible couple of months he
regained consciousness
enough that they accepted him to a rehab
hospital eight hours away they said for
two months we'll do rehab and do the
best that we can so I packed up left my
kids with family members and I went
to this rehab hospital for two months
and that two-month stay due to a very
curious stroke and seizures turned into
a seventh month day
and we finally got to go home he came
home with a trache in
um a feeding tube in his stomach I had
to learn how to put a catheter in I'll
you know I learned how to take care of
him so we could bring him home
I had so much Faith John the whole time
he would be healed I just I knew it and
I'm a religious person and we had so
much faith and we worked
so hard I knew he would be he would get
better at least better enough that we
could carry on a conversation with him
he would be somewhat himself
and over the next two years of having it
him at home it was a lot of work
um and he just never really
got better he did learn to walk again we
taught him to walk
um but ultimately his injuries are
he lost hearing he's completely deaf
um and he has no short-term memory so we
can't even teach him sign language
because he can't learn new things he
knows my kids
um he knows anything that happened 10
years ago or more but anything that's
happened about two years before the
accident and anything current he has no
idea he doesn't remember he's had three
kids get married he has grandkids I have
an eight-year-old he was kind of our
surprise baby and he doesn't he knows
that he has an eight-year-old but
doesn't really know him he forgets their
name sometimes
he has no concept of space or time or
age or distance all of that part of his
brain was
damaged
um
and two years ago
I decided for the sake of my kids lives
moving on in mind that I needed to put
him into a facility so he's in an
assisted living facility just a few
miles from home we go see him all the
time
um a couple months after we put him in
that facility we made some medical
decisions decided it was time to let him
go
and we put him on hospice and thought
the time would come that he would pass
and it's been almost two years and
despite
all medical odds science everything he's
still with us
pretty much no quality of life we've
prepared ourselves to let him go so many
times when it looked like everything was
heading that direction
and he's still with us and it's just
been so hard
to know how to move on
um
through this process I got my master's
degree
I you know I went back to school I I was
recently I've become an lcpc so I'm able
to work now and provide for my family
awesome so my question is sorry that
took so long but here's my question hold
on hold on hold on before we ask you a
question okay can I just sit with you in
that for a minute
yeah
that's so so much
this could be a whole Hollywood movie
that would last 10 hours so my um oldest
best friend on planet Earth
is a traumatic brain Survivor and
um
when I'm with him now we go out I stop
to help him go to the bathroom
um stuff to start to have people take
care of and help him
um
and I can't imagine going up 100x that
with building a life with somebody
because it changes everything right
oh man changes the way you breathe
yep
and my guess is as a Mom of eight
you've been solving and fixing for five
years
yeah I have been and you went and got a
freaking master's degree
like at some point it's at some point I
know have you exhaled
you know after about year one I did and
I still had so much hope and so much
faith and we would work with him every
day work on walking work on brain stuff
like don't let them just sit in front of
the TV like we gotta work with them it's
gonna get better it's gonna get better
and then after about year three
I just really had to shift my thinking
that this isn't going to turn out
how I thought it would
um so we cut we've we've come to peace
with it in fact we've come we came to so
much peace with him passing
that is what we've been praying for for
the last two years that it would be
better for him I mean you know you talk
about your friend and and how that is
with him my husband is the same way he
would be humiliated to see what he has
become this is not what he would want
it's not this is not the kind of life I
mean he if he had his right sense he
would say why didn't you just let me go
three years ago why did you keep me
alive
and I listened to your last caller and
it breaks my heart the loss that she
feels and do you know what I'm thinking
is
why can't I be one of the people whose
husbands get to pass I'm in a position
where I'm jealous
of women
whose husbands just get to go peacefully
and don't have to live through
this pain and Agony that my family lives
through every day
I'm so sorry
[Music]
yeah sorry
because you're right you're right
hold on you don't have to make me feel
better you've been you you do that too
much to everybody around you
finally get a glimpse they finally get a
little peek behind the curtain and they
realize how much you're hurting you have
become so accustomed to making sure
everybody around you feels okay
and at least at least for these few
minutes that's not your job with me
I get to be sad
that in the in the effort to save
somebody's life yet again we got so
sophisticated with our medical care that
we have put families in these positions
and
I'm sorry
so what's your dilemma question
[Music]
um one of my husband's old friends that
I didn't know before we knew each other
reached out I I had a CaringBridge
account you know Facebook I kind of
would keep friends and family up to date
and I haven't posted anything for a
really long time so he just reached out
said how is he doing how's the family
doing
So I responded and we kind of struck up
this friendship
um oh no no Diane no no no no no listen
it did not go where you think it's going
that's my dilemma but it was just nice
it was it was nice to have somebody talk
to me
on that level it was nice to have
somebody check in at night saying how
are you doing he's divorced so he's
single but I'm married and I promise you
it has not gone anywhere
you're not crazy you're not a bad person
okay here's my question okay it's this
is
this is a doozy
there's no doozies on the show go for it
I am considering
getting a divorce Okay so
they'll move on with my life
okay
nothing with my relationship with my
husband would change one thing I didn't
say about his
um
you know kind of his personalities he
he's very apathetic he doesn't care
about anything
I walk in he smiles at me I could tell
him
his kids took his truck and wrecked it
or whatever he wouldn't he wouldn't care
he isn't capable
of caring about anything so we go see
him it's mostly for us he doesn't
remember he doesn't really care
and
um just this little encounter I've had
with this man it made you feel it made
you feel alive really made you feel
alive again yeah absolutely like would
it be so bad if I divorced him just for
the sake of
getting my feet out of the concrete I
feel like I'm stuck in and start to
imagine
a future because for so long we thought
he's going to pass any day any day any
day any day and we've lived thinking
he's gonna pass and now I'm thinking
he could live another 10 or 20 years
like his heart and lungs are pretty dang
good his brain's pretty shot but he
could live
a long time
like this
and what does that mean for me and my
kids
I
it sounds like in all of the
if I was to distill down
well let me say this I want to be
careful how I do this because I don't
want anyone listening to this to think
this is the right path for somebody
who's having this conversation okay so I
am I am collapsing what would be a long
time of you and I getting to know each
other and hanging out and me getting to
hear all the stories and developing a
relationship with you before I started
asking you these questions okay you know
more than anybody else listening
how awful and Thoughtless and dumb and
just stitched into pillows the sayings
you get lobbed at you all the time right
you've got that for five years okay
right so I don't wanna I don't want to
contribute to that
but at the same time for the sake of
this I've got I've gotta expedite a lot
of this okay so this is just you and me
same side of the same side of the booth
just figuring this out okay actually I'm
not really the same side of the booth
kind of guy so we're looking across from
the booth at each other
um
it sounds like
through all of your prayers
the chief prayer overall has been
I want this to be exactly as I want it
I want this to the outcome of this to be
exactly what I want it to be
and
wrestling with praying for and I've done
this
praying for someone that I love to go
ahead and pass and then they don't and
then I have the guilt that I prayed for
them to die
and I can't breathe
and then I go through these like well I
guess I'll I guess they're here to teach
me something as though that's their job
right it just it just it never stops it
never stops right right I'm supposed to
get out of this there's still something
I'm supposed to learn that's right
I guess you said it best earlier
it's there's a coming to terms with the
fact that all the things you've prayed
for the last five years many of them
have come true they just haven't come
true in the ways that you wanted them to
yeah and the great challenge of just
being alive
is dealing with that gap of what we
wanted versus what we get
what I thought this would look like
versus reality and that's the worst
that's grief right that's the black hole
and so go about going back to what you
said
this is for you
I would suggest
you're not crazy
I can't imagine how alive you must feel
to have somebody checking on you
who also might be a little bit cute
mm-hmm I cannot imagine
how lonely it is
not being intimate with somebody when
they're right there
all of it all of it
but just from the few minutes I've heard
you on the phone I'm trying to project
out a year from now
would you be able to breathe
this isn't a judgment question at all
it's a curious question this is me just
asking Diane
if I were to divorce him would I be able
to breathe is that what you're asking me
I think I would
I I don't foresee that me getting a
divorce would change anything with him I
would have nothing to do with him has
nothing to do with him
it has to do with you saying for
sickness and health
right
I know he he won't know up from down
day one from day seven he won't know
you will
and so as as terms of your Covenant like
this idea and again I use that word
intentionally and I'm not even using it
in a religious context I'm just saying
there's so few Forevers anymore in our
culture
if you say no no I'm in forever and
then I don't have to look Diane in the
mirror you do
so if it's like yeah no I've done I've
done my duty and if my husband was alive
today nobody knows him like me it's been
30 years together
um he would be saying what are you doing
go hook up with one of my greatest
friends yes at least you'd be taken care
of
um
or
if you say I'm gonna figure out how to
feel alive and be alive inside of the
parameters life inside of this deck of
card this hand of cards that life has to
help me
because I said forever
I guess at the end of the day I can't
let you off the hook either way
yeah I can tell you
what I would do but I don't think that's
helpful here and I can also tell you
telling you what I would do right now on
this side of this thing actually
happening probably isn't um even true
yeah this is not something I in fact
people started
asking me early on you know would you
have you know have you thought about
divorcing them what did you and I just
was like absolutely not like that is a
ridiculous
idea
and it's just been long enough
I know if it were if the roles were
reversed
knowing what I know now I would tell him
go find somebody
go find somebody to be with and
be happy with and one thing you know I
am a religious person I've talked a lot
about prayer and faith and my religion
my husband and I were married in our in
our Temple and we were married for
what we call time in all eternity and so
one thing I know is if I were divorced
from him it would separate us for this
life but I know and fully intend on
living with him in the next life
forever and I know that that's something
in my religion that some man would be
very cautious to even date me knowing
that I have been sealed
to my husband because that would mean
that whatever marriage we have
fear would not
extend beyond this life
if that makes sense just you know kind
of as a frame of reference for where I
am at sure I I mean I don't have any
reference point for your religious
background but I would say based on what
you just said
if there is a if this is a cosmic
linkage if this is a forever together
what's the rush
if you truly believe that
uh-huh
and I do
and I know everything is going to work
out I know God's got a plan and in the
end it's gonna be but you don't like his
plan
I don't like it I don't like it can't
help but think with 30 more years in me
in this life
would it
you know is this idea of finding
somebody to have some companionship with
for the next
20 30 years
I know where I I can tell what you're
thinking and I'm writing it can you tell
that yeah you don't know you don't know
what I'm thinking you know what I'm
thinking I'm thinking I'm thinking how
hard this is
um
and ultimately my my biggest you know
I've got an eight-year-old like I said
my next oldest is 16 and my you know
I've got older kids out of the house and
he is my biggest
concern at this point is this
eight-year-old that I have still at home
and in no way would I ever
do anything that would
you know make life harder for him or
jeopardize my relationship with him
for sure
well again not a judgment question but
just a question question
curiosity question
would you be showing that eight-year-old
that there is a boundary
to Forever
there comes a day when Mom moves on
what do you think
um
I don't know that's a tough one
I guess I guess I'll
I I'm not gonna give you the
satisfaction of telling you what I
really think give me permission no
chance just tell me what I want to hear
nobody ever does listen no I I
I hear a woman who deeply loves her
husband
I hear a woman who
has not yet opened her hands up to the
fact that you can't control any of this
and every step of the way you're
continuing to control continue to try to
control and continue to try to control
even to the point that you got everybody
together to plan for
the end
that you don't get to decide
and so
there's no possible way
I'm gonna sit in Judgment of you on any
decision that you make
I do believe that you get to choose to
feel alive and to be alive in whatever
context you find
I also believe that
for sickness and in health and Covenant
I don't know still means something
uh-huh
and
I'm trying to think of what my life
would be like dating Diane
who's like no no I still love this guy
I'm linked cosmically forever this guy
I'm still gonna go take care of him
every week I just needed some cover so
you and I could hook up
there are certainly
will take up on that
and that's what I said like say I go
ahead and do this like what guy in his
right mind oh don't be a line of him
Diane there's a bunch of just Shady
people out there no they'll be there
they'll be there
um they'll be there no question
but it all comes back to you
it comes back to you
and just talking to you I think you're
exhausted
and every plan you've made along the way
for the last five years has not worked
out as you wanted it to
and so your next option to try to
control what happens next
is what it sounds like to me to violate
one of your core tenants one of your
core beliefs religiously one of your
core beliefs in love
because you're real lonely
and you're really exhausted
but again it looks like yet another
attempt to control what happens next
because you've been out of control for
five years and I would suggest before
you go file for divorce
you spend some time with open hands
and fully leaning into probably with
your kids too
I don't control any of the outcomes now
and I'm gonna stop racing and seeking to
try to find another outcome that I can
control
and God Almighty yes it feels good when
people reach out
that feels good when you've been married
and you're happily married it feels good
when somebody reaches out and tells you
they miss you or they like you or
checking in on you
I would tell you to take a break
take a break from visiting for a bit
take a break from the divorce
conversation for a bit take a break from
talking to this guy for a bit
and maybe your prayer switch is from
okay what about this okay what about
this okay what about this
and instead your prayer switch is to
I've got no control and I've got no
power
please lead me into what comes next
and again I don't know your faith
tradition I don't don't know your
religious tradition I know
you've been trying to control stuff for
a long long time
so sorry I can't give you I can't give
you my truest deepest thoughts on this
one
um what I can tell you is
unhook all the brakes
and just sit for a minute
maybe talk to your kids
maybe get some wisdom from your friends
but seek to be alive outside of some new
romantic relationship for just a minute
seek to be at peace
seek to open your hands and say okay I
control nothing
get me through tomorrow
and really dig in on the promises that
you made for forever
because you're the one that made them
and if you make this other choice you're
gonna be the one that breaks them
and Diane's gonna have to live with
Diane
thank you so much I'm so grateful for
your bravery you're awesome call anytime